some things that are just like too much
well let's make it and find out if it's
tasty or not
i'm working mama
what the hell are you gonna be doing
so joyce and i were chatting about
unconventional
food pairings and one particularly stood
out to us cheese and apple pie
apple
pie american
apple pie
what everyone needs a slice of cheese
cheddar cheese and apple pie is
apparently definitely a thing so our
challenge today is to kind of
make it and find out if it's tasty or
not i just really want to know like what
it's like what they love about it so
let's see if there's anyone here that
has had it before okay i trust the tasty
audience opinion okay we're gonna ask
him yeah
now let's wait for the results
what the hell you got me doing
looks like someone in our office has had
it patrick hi patrick hello hello hey
patrick thank you for having me cheddar
apple pie love and patrick okay all
right i've tried this type of pie before
and it wasn't terrible i mean i didn't
think it was that big of a deal quite
honestly i'm very confident that we'll
all you're gonna have a slice and you're
gonna be like wow what was i thinking
and maybe it'll be your new favorite pie
choice to be my favorite pie you have to
work for it you have to twerk for it you
have to pay the rent for it are you
twerking for prize now always no dude
all right so i have a bunch of work to
do but i can't wait to come back and try
this pie it's gonna be great yes okay
get out of my face you got it bye
patrick if i had to make a cheddar
cheese apple pie i gotta make it my own
and really make it intentional hopefully
it'll be something that we both like for
some reason i thought the cheese grater
wasn't me
so peel it first with us okay
we're gonna be here for a while cool
let's make crust i have flour some salt
a little bit of sugar i'm gonna get some
butter and cheese
all right let me grab it once i was a
peeler i was petrified peeling apples
every day of my stinking life okay great
so i'm just going to cut this up into
like
chunks it's going to give us our flaky
crust now normally with this pie crust i
would put in three sticks of butter and
this is two because
cheese
i'm still peeling i mean it's gonna do
very similar
job as a butter but just add in that
extra flavor are those apples coming
i'm working mama
okay um if you could please hand me that
large pitcher of water i have ice
ooh ice just like my exes say i am hmm
all right ice cream okay i thought
you're gonna hand that to me and i made
an awkward move can't wait for america
to trash me speaking of america what are
the kids saying the poll was at 17
yes 83
no honestly 17 is a higher than i
thought we have someone say nasty
because of the texture and the saltiness
gross i don't know because it's tasty
that's disgusting put a scoop of vanilla
ice cream like a normal human being
apple pie without cheddar cheese is like
a hug without the squeeze hashtag
vermont but if a whole state europe
stands by it like it can't be wrong yeah
how does apple's coming along i did
three so you're halfway there
she knows i'm lazy i'm gonna chill this
dough kind of looks like the dough for
the red lobster biscuits i have never
frequented them for lobster
i'm gonna put these in the fridge okay
i'm really not good at angling this
thing like i'm too aggressive for that i
just like to destroy are you almost good
at those apples i can lend you a hand
oh now she wants to assist when most of
the work is done actually i will help
you slice the apples since you're doing
such a splendid job at peeling them
[Music]
so now that our apples are peeled cut
sliced it's time to make the filling so
we're gonna
drain this off and then masquerade the
apples this is like what makes
the pie magic
this step right here
this is it because usually no feeling
comes in a can
oh god now
straining the draining mattress
so we're not gonna add like a crazy
amount of sugar but we're gonna use two
cans
some brown sugar and some white sugar a
little bit of this
[Music]
i love brown sugar
it's so pretty like me brown sugar is
fast
cinnamon
all spice have you ever had jerk chicken
yeah that's what it's like this is like
that this is what gives jerk chicken
that flavor and it goes but not too much
fresh nutmeg fresh you gotta have it
fresh wow
look how pretty it is on the inside
look at that
you don't like the way i look what do
you mean
i have typophobia
trypaphobia yeah
now
salt helps us enhance whatever flavors
you're working with yes i've used salt
before you want to give it a squeeze of
lemon oh god finally make sure you don't
get seeds in there
see you see it coming out oh boy i'm
sorry i'm stronger than i look so i'm
going to use a mix of thickener flour
and cornstarch now everything's in there
we're just going to
mix all together and the macerating
process of like just letting it sit down
is what's going to soften the apples
this is like the dream team this is like
nba circa those
car malone yeah jordan yeah scottie
pippen
yes
i think they are all beautiful and
combined yes i massaged them just the
way you asked me to
i said toss not massage
mastery key to cooking is tasting along
the way because
it tastes good
now it's like i don't even need to eat a
pie i just had a whole pie experience so
i have our chilled doughs we're just
gonna each roll one out just like press
press press
[Music]
boom
so i think my crosstalk is big enough do
you want to give it a go so guys welcome
to joyce's kitchen we have a visiting
death her name is
guest so then i'm going to put a little
flower on this because you know
chef 4rd i went to the school of chef
bar id yeah you know chef ready was a
real dude right really his ravioli is
good though i've heard
i'm doing this right right maybe two you
can also flip it hmm
so in an hour when joyce is done rolling
out a piece of dough we're going to put
together the pie i'm going to kill her
this is really good hand massage
oh that one's definitely going on the
wall
oh
i'm out i'm out i don't even i'm out i
feel like i'm going to destroy this i am
very in sweet spots i'm i want to be
delicate but i'm not high time bye time
to make sure it all makes it to the pan
you're just going to roll your dough
onto the rolling pin
and then unroll it onto the pan
so now that the bottom one is in there
we can start layering the apples the
most important part is to make sure that
there's no gaps i can make sure there's
no gaps i do that with my foundation
every day
i'm gonna help you out a little bit just
to it's like i'm too slow for you tasty
folks so i just wanna get it in my belly
asap
boom boom boom yes
i'm a crust queen
i forgot what we were doing this is a
cheese pie so i was like so excited to
eat you can see all the cheese right now
so now that all this is done what i'm
going to do is i'm gonna flute the edges
take your fingers like crab claw and
another finger goes like that
but in the pie you definitely floating
the heck out of it you must be a master
fluter
so final step this is what makes it nice
and shiny and beautiful
do an egg wash just like one egg just
beating up
i'm just gonna paint the pie
yes paint paint paint paint it's a final
step before
pop it in the oven fragrance the kitchen
with that cheesy cinnamony
delight
i can't believe i'm eating this my
stomach really hurts
to the other
after an hour of baking your prize will
look something like this so we have two
pie situations happening over here we
have the og classic apple pie and we
just melted a piece of cheese on top and
then the one we made with the cheddar
crust
also with the cheese on top i'm excited
to try so let's get patrick in here so
you can try it with us
patrick
hello
we have pie for you have you tried them
yet no we haven't tried we're waiting
for you okay
so i think maybe we should start with
the traditional one first
okay okay not like underwhelming but it
was a lot is calm yeah no i love this
this was delightful so this one has
cheddar in the crust as well as on top
i love that
oh
i tasted a lot more in here way more
very decadent now day is over is apple
pie with cheese on top tasty
it's tasty it is like i'm not mad that
it is i'm actually glad i would have
hated for us to put all this work and
for it to be like but somehow
you know it holds a tone against the pie
but it doesn't overtake it well
cheddar
apple pie lovers i understand i get you
i just think the hardest part of me is
swallowing my pride and saying that's
wrong
i wonder what other foods that's when
eggs is delicious crazy yo you are crazy
some things that are just like too much
i heard ketchup and cereal
too much
that one's too much you have to bleep
that that is like so offensive
[Music]
you